bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct de la salle des conférences du
sénat pour la séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement que vous
allez pouvoir suivre en direct sur notre
antenne dans 15 minutes mais tout
d'abord on fait un peu un point sur
l'actualité avec notre invité de la
première partie de cette émission pierre
laurent sénateur communiste bonjour
merci d'être avec nous déjà une première
réaction je viens de recevoir cette
information la justice autorise sephora
à ouvrir le soir c'est un combat qui
était mené par sephora notamment pour
ses magasins parisiens je crois qu'il
est temps de légiférer il ya une
offensive qui est continu pour
déréglementer le temps de travail le
dimanche le soir et je pense que c'est
une mauvaise nouvelle et il faudrait à
nouveau encadrer cette question pour
éviter que ce soit à la justice de
trancher mais ça devrait être la loi qui
encadre à nouveau cette situation il ya
plusieurs salariés qui s'était associé à
la direction de safara pour demander l
ouverture nocturne
on sait très bien pourquoi les salariés
ont des salaires qui n'augmentent plus
voir qui recule avec la précarité est
donc évidemment la seule manière pour
eux d'améliorer un petit peu leur
pouvoir d'achat
c'est d'allonger leur temps de travail
avec des heures supplémentaires donc
peut-être qu'il ya autre chose à faire
que mettre les salariés dans cette
taille ou travailler tard le soir ou le
dimanche pour pouvoir gagner un peu plus
ou alors accepter des bas salaires on
peut peut-être relever les salaires
et puis encadrer davantage les gens qui
pourront d'ailleurs faire autre chose de
leur argent au moment du temps libre
l'allongement de la durée d'ouverture
des magasins ça ne crée pas des emplois
selon vous sans emploi en france
l'expérience montre que depuis qu'on a
depuis maintenant des années d'offensive
on a plutôt une montée de la
précarisation de l'emploi et dans toutes
les grandes zones qu'ils ont
du travail le dimanche ou du travail
tard le soir on a une une explosion des
contrats précaires donc ça va plutôt de
pair avec la précarisation de l'emploi
dans le commerce
pierre laurent vous allez interpellé
dans quelques minutes dans l'hémicycle
premier ministre sur le dossier
arcelormittal à florange
vous allez demander quoi jean marc
ayrault cet après midi il faut ouvrir
sans délai le dossier sur l'avenir
industriel du site parce que le premier
ministre dit on à conserver l'emploi est
ce que fait le gouvernement en ce moment
des négociations indique me tallend il y
a on nous dit on garantit l'emploi mais
sur le volet industriel toutes les
interrogations demeurent puisque les
hauts fourneaux reste fermé on vient
d'apprendre ce matin que mittal alors
que le premier ministre a dit qu'il
avait obtenu la réouverture du la
reprise du projet ou le coz qui est donc
le projet du futur de la future
production d'acier à basse intensité en
émissions carbone et bien mittal annonce
que finalement il vient de retirer son
dossier de candidature dans l'appel
d'offres européen donc les engagements
des filières
il envisage peut-être de leur déposer
ultérieurement oui mais pendant ce temps
là il ya un appel d'offres européen il
ya d'autres dossiers de candidature on
est en train de perdre beaucoup de temps
probablement de perdre la main sur ce
dossier
donc c'est une des questions je vais
poser au premier ministre parce qu'on
voit bien que on a détricotage des
prétendus engagement industriel de
mittal et malheureusement ça n'est pas
une surprise parce qu'on serait on sait
très bien que le groupe mittal veut se
désengager progressivement de toute la
filière chaude en europe
et si on le laisse faire on mettra en
danger toute la filière sidérurgique
donc la question qui a été posée au
départ elle revient c'est à l'état de
prendre ses responsabilités de reprendre
la main dans ce dossier industriel est
ce que c'est à l'état de soutenir à bout
de bras cette filière vous dites que me
talbot sans dégâts veut s'en désengager
il est pas le seul
il ya plusieurs grands groupes
sidérurgiques aussi qu'ils lisent et
engage de cette filière au niveau
européen
mais d'une part c'est une filière
stratégique parce qu'on consomme de
l'acier dans toutes les grandes filières
industrielles donc si on laisse filer la
maîtrise de
de l'industrie sidérurgique on le paiera
très cher dans toutes les filiales
industrielles et deuxièmement pourquoi
vous êtes filet parce que la main
d'oeuvre européenne n'est plus assez
compétitive non pas du tout parce que
parce qu'ils veulent des taux de
rentabilité qui sont qui sont
insupportables et ils préfèrent protéger
des autos des autos de rentabilité que
l'intérêt national
et ça n'est pas une filière tenu à bout
de bras parce qu'il ya un projet un
rapport officiel
moi je m'étonne qu'on n'en parle pas
plus ce qu'on nous a beaucoup parlé du
rapport gallois mais le gouvernement a
commandé un rapport sur florent le
rapport fort
personne n'en parle or ce rapport dit
que le site de florange à condition de
le maintenir dans sa tête dans sa
cohérence et rentable qu'il faut
investir dans son avenir qu'il faut une
option nationale pour la sidérurgie
pourquoi est ce que le gouvernement
enterre ce rapport et n'en parle plus
jean françois copé a déclaré ce matin
jean marc ayrault est totalement dépassé
et françois hollande totalement absent
vous êtes d'accord avec lui non je ne
suis pas c'est c'est pas la droite qui a
laissé filer ce dossier qui de la même
manière à laisser mittal imposer sa loi
qui a fait des promesses aussi qu'il n'a
jamais tenus sur gandrange qui va venir
des donner des leçons au gouvernement
donc nous nous parlons au nom des
syndicalistes ou non de salariés qui
n'arrive pas à se faire entendre et e
qui eux attendent de ce gouvernement des
engagements plus fermes
on a quand même l'impression que le
premier ministre est assez isolée sur sa
position je crois que il a il affiche le
problème du gouvernement c'est qu'ils
affichent des intentions qui sont
soutenus par les par les salariés du
site mais que les résultats pour les
mettre en oeuvre ne sont pas là et donc
il ya une forme de colère des salariés
devant ce grand écart mais le
gouvernement a la possibilité de changer
de braquet mais il faut qu'ils rouvrent
maintenant le dossier de l'avenir
industriel du site de florange l'accord
le prétendu accord avec mittal parce que
on sait plus très bien ce qui a vraiment
de sueur dans cet accord et bien ne ne
fait pas le compte donc il faut ré
ouvrir le dossier sangla selon vous
aujourd'hui
oui il faut tout remettre à plat il faut
reprendre il faut ouvrir
je vais faire une proposition en tout
cas je vais poser la question premier
ministre il a parlé d'un comité de suivi
moi je propose qu'on élargisse
composition de ce comité de suivi et sa
mission qui ne soit pas seulement de
suivre l'accord tel qu'il a été soi
disant signé avec mittal mais qu'ils
soient de réouvrir le travail sur la
construction de pistes industrielle
nouvelle pour le site de florange et
pour la sidérurgie plus globalement
élargir acquis par exemple à des par
exemple d'une représentation pluraliste
des élus locaux des élus nationaux il
faudrait que des parlementaires intègre
ce comité de suivi de manière à ce qu'on
travaille aux côtés des syndicats dans
la plus totale transparence parce qu'un
des problèmes de ce dossier c'est
l'absence de transparence des
spécialistes de la filière
et puis que tout ce monde travaille
ensemble mais il faut reconstruire
maintenant des solutions industrielles
d'avenir et je pense que c'est possible
vous aimeriez quel président un public
montrent un peu plus au créneau dans ces
dossiers écouter s'il ne monte pas au
créneau sur des dossiers aussi décisif
pour l'avenir du pays que ce celui de
l'avenir de la filière sidérurgique
autant dire que tout le discours sur la
relance industrielle n'a pas de sens
donc bon il a des ministres il a un
premier ministre donc il s'agit pas que
françois hollande parle tous les jours
et sur tous les sujets moi c'est pas ma
conception de la république mais aussi
un jardin ce sujet il appuie les
dossiers très importants la plus
symbolique
oui c'est des dossiers stratégiques pour
le pays une nature ouais est-ce qu'on en
dévalorisant un peu le projet d'arnaud
montebourg est-ce que jean marc ayrault
n'a pas un peu dévalorisés aussi cet
accord signé avec metal je crois qu'il a
il a peut-être un peu trop cédé à la
pression qui s'exerçait on a entendu
madame parisot la semaine dernière bien
là la nationalisation surtout pas alors
qu'on voit aujourd'hui surtout après
l'annnonce de mittal ce matin sur ulcos
ce qu'il faut que l'état s'en mêle si
l'état ne prend pas la main dans ce
dossier et laisse les mains libres à
metal on ira vers vers une catastrophe
demain le conseil constitionnel va
peut-être annulé l'élection législative
d'hénin-beaumont six aides et aline et
est ce que jean luc mélenchon doit se
représenter face à marine le pen d'abord
l'élection n'est pas annulée
donc vous avez étudié les deux
hypothèses calenge et on a étudié les
deux hypothèses bien sûr j'espère que
l'élection sera pas annulée tout cas moi
je ne le souhaite pas mais c'est pas moi
c'est le saura demain
deuxième hypothèse si elle était mise et
amis potez je pense qu' il faudrait
étudier la possibilité de rassembler le
maximum de forces pour empêcher parce
qu'on sait bien que c'est son objectif
l'élection de marine le pen
moi je pense que il faut créer les
meilleures conditions pour empêcher
cette élection est ce que ça dida unique
à gauche
si on peut trouver un très bon candidat
de rassemblement de tout le monde
peut-être peut-être ça passe aussi par
une candidature on nous y allons au
premier tour il faut étudier les deux
hypothèses mais attendons d'abord de
savoir si l'élection est à lui et si
elle l'est pour quelles raisons et
ensuite on programme décimé jean luc
mélenchon est ce qu'il va repartir dans
ce combat nm on l'a dit il a dit qu'il
était qu'il était disponible mais qu'il
attendrait aussi l'avis des militants
locaux ce qui est normal qu'est ce que
vous pensez de la récente conversion à
l'écologie de jean luc mélenchon il
vient de sortir un livre sur ce thème
c'est pas une récente conversion ni
d'ailleurs de jean luc mélenchon ni du
parti communiste et du front de gauche
nous avons mené la campagne
présidentielle à nos mots d'ordre les
plus importants qui recouvrait beaucoup
de propositions était celui de la
planification écologique et dans la
campagne présidentielle
nous avons été en matière de
propositions écologiques parmi les plus
performants des candidats mais quand
même donc choisi distingue des verts par
exemple je pense au dossier du nucléaire
par exemple oui mais il y a bien sûr des
sur des débats mais en tout cas cette
cette question écologique est une
question qui nous qui nous préoccupe au
plus haut point qui fait partie
maintenant du coeur de nos propositions
où en sont les discussions entre le
parti communiste et le parti socialiste
vous devez normalement vous rencontrez
assez régulièrement avec harlem désir
on s'est vus pour la première fois dans
une rencontre officielle la semaine
prochaine ça a été une explication
politique une discussion politique sur
ce que sont nos positionnements
respectifs en ce moment notamment ici au
sénat avec des thèses qui est des textes
qui ont été rejetées on peut le rappeler
notamment le projet de loi de finances
oui
qui sont rejetés pour des raisons
précises c'est que nous nous pensons
qu'il faudrait avancer plus résolument
dans le sens de la mobilisation des
ressources nationales pour le
redressement social
le redressement productif c'est parce
qu'on se donne pas assez ces moyens là
que nous critiquons le projet de budget
donc c'est un débat que nous avons
effectivement avec harlem désir avec le
parti socialiste est aujourd'hui nous ne
sommes pas d'accord sur le cap qui est
pris mais c'est un débat politique qui
va continuer et qui nous empêche pas
d'avoir des contacts réguliers nous en
aurons d'autres j'espère on voit mal
comment quand même vous pourriez vous
accorder sur le virage social libérale
actuelle du gouvernement
écoutez il ya quelques semaines qui
aurait dit que la nationalisation de
florange faisait partie du débat
gouvernemental et pourtant c'est le cas
mais j'ai retenu sept national est
arrivé il ya des idées nouvelles qui
progressivement prennent leur place dans
le débat à gauche
ico et je pense que ça peut continuer à
avancer parce que la crise est là et
qu'il faudra trouver des solutions et
qu'il faudra innover
donc ceux qui nous disent mon at on
avait tous pensé l'année dernière dont
il ya beaucoup de problèmes devant nous
et les idées du front gauche vont être
utiles à résoudre ces problèmes
vous en tête malgré tout qu'elle est
question au sein du parti socialiste
notamment la gauche du parti socialiste
y compris ici au parlement au sénat ou à
l'assemblée nationale bien sûr il ya
beaucoup de préoccupations
d'interrogation par exemple le
l'assemblée vient d'en discuter on va en
parler au sénat le projet de loi de
finances rectificatif qui met en musique
le pacte de compétitivité 20 milliards
de crédit d'impôt sans contrepartie est
ce que c'est la bonne idée
nous ne pensons pas mais je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de parlementaires
socialistes qui se pose la même question
que nous sur ce point mois sur l'absence
de contrepartie selon vous dans le
projet du gouvernement y ait encore des
amendements qui peuvent être votées
notamment est ici au sénat quand les
textes à venir en discussion
j'imagine que votre groupe va en
proposer jalons en proposer absolument
nous allons proposer je pense qu'il faut
par exemple exclure du bénéfice de ce
crédit d'impôt des groupes qui
distribuent des dividendes et qui en
même temps continuer à supprimer des
emplois parce que si on fait rien on
parlait de mittal mittal va toucher
l'argent de crédit d'impôt sanofi qui
fait énormément de profits et qui
licencient va toucher le crédit d'impôt
donc on va donner une prime à des
stratégies financières qui détruisent
l'emploi alors qu'on prétend que le
crédit d'impôt devrait servir à linverse
on va peut-être finir cette interview de
pierre laurent par un hommage à oscar
niemeyer qui a notamment construit et le
siège du parti communiste à paris de
quelle façon le parti va lui rendre
hommage dans les jours à venir
on a on a ouvert dès ce matin comment un
registre pour aller rendre hommage ça
permettra aussi aux gens de découvrir le
siège qui ne l'ont pas vu et très
probablement mais je peux pas vous
annoncer la date parce qu'on l'a pas
encore fixé mais on fera des journées
portes ouvertes parce que le meilleur
moyen qu'on puisse pour lui rendre
hommage
c'est de permettre aux parisiens aux
français de découvrir ce joyau de
l'architecturé moderne
merci beaucoup pierre laurent d'avoir
été sur notre plateau on reparlera
peut-être d'oscar niemeyer qui était
aussi un homme engagé
ça sera une autre façon aussi de
communiste fidel il jusqu'à la fin de
ses jours et jusqu'à ses 104 ans
puisqu'il est il est mort cette nuit
merci père laurent ça sonne je vous
laisse donc rejoindre la séance
l'hémicycle du sénat pour cette séance
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement qui va démarrer dans
quelques instants alors parmi les thèmes
abordés cet après-midi et bien il y aura
bien sûr la question de pierre laurent
sur arcelormittal et le site de florange
il y aura d'ailleurs deux questions
consacré à ce sujet hautement
d'actualité
cet après midi dans l'hémicycle du sénat
le chômage des jeunes la précarité la
progression également de la preuve de la
pauvreté dans la société française et
bien trois questions tourneront autour
de ces thématiques
cet après midi et les ministres du
gouvernement répondront bien sûr aux
sénateurs une question également sur
l'autisme alors qu'aujourd'hui est
organisé toute la journée au sénat un
grand colloque autour de la prise en
charge de l'autisme en france voilà un
certain nombre de thématiques que vous
allez pouvoir suivre en direct sur notre
antenne on le voit sur ces images et
bien le président de séance le président
du sénat se dirige vers l'hémicycle du
sénat pour présider ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement donc dans
voilà il n'a plus que quelques pas à
faire et dans quelques secondes
il sera dans l'hémicycle il pourra
s'installer à la présidence de séance et
les questions d'actualité vont pouvoir
démarrer sur notre antenne
jean marc ayrault devrait répondre en
personne tout à l'heure à la question de
pierre laurent c'est la question numéro
trois sur arcelormittal florange est la
question la plus attendue cet après-midi
dans l'hémicycle du sénat on va la
suivre avec intérêt d'ici quelques
instants
voilà la version je vous laisse la
suivre en direct à tout à l'heure avec
nos invités comme ces messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues l'ordre du
jour appelle les questions d'actualité
au gouvernement
je rappelle cette fois encore que
l'auteur de la question
de même que le ministre ou la ministre
pour sa réponse se disposent chacun de
deux minutes trente
la parole est à monsieur claude gillet
pour le groupe socialiste et apparentés
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames messieurs les ministres
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre le 11 février 1987 il y
à 25 ans joseph wresinski fait adopter
par le conseil économique et social de
l'époque un rapport intitulé grande
pauvreté et précarité économique et
sociale en 2011
le rapport de l'observatoire national de
la pauvreté et de l'exclusion sociale
constaté que plus de 11 millions de
personnes en france étaient touchées par
la pauvreté ou l'exclusion et que la
pauvreté sous toutes ses formes n'a
cessé d'augmenter
parmi les personnes les plus vulnérables
il y a les familles monoparentales les
jeunes les femmes âgées sans oublier
aussi la pauvreté des enfants
l'observatoire constate aussi que
disposer d'un emploi n'est plus une
condition suffisante pour franchir le
seuil de la pauvreté dans l'emploi s'est
raréfiée et précarisées
la pauvreté augmente mais aussi elle se
territorialise en france un individu
peut être considérée comme pauvre quand
ses revenus mensuels sont inférieurs à
964 euros
or 33% des personnes vivant dans les
banlieues sensibles vivent avec moins de
900 euros par mois
le revenu fiscal moyen de la population
des zones urbaines sensibles s'élève à
environ 60% de celui de l'agglomération
qui abrite le quartier
monsieur le premier ministre lors de la
préparation de la conférence contre la
pauvreté et pour l'inclusion sociale des
10 et 11 décembre prochains
vous avez affirmé que vous alliez dégagé
une enveloppe de 50 millions sur le
budget des ministères qui seront
répartis entre les crédits de la veille
sociale de l'hébergement d'urgence et de
la prise en charge des demandeurs
d'asile l'objectif de votre gouvernement
est bien de réduire les inégalités et
d'éviter que des hommes et des femmes ne
tombe dans une précarité dramatique pour
eux-mêmes mais aussi pour notre pays
alors monsieur le premier ministre
pourriez-vous nous dire quelle mesure
votre gouvernement compte prendre en
urgence d'abord mais ensuite quelles
actions les ministres qui participeront
aux ateliers de cette conférence avec le
conseil national des politiques de lutte
contre la pauvreté et l'exclusion
sociale
envisage-t-il de prendre pour réduire
ces situations sur le long terme
merci la parole est à monsieur jean marc
ayrault premier ministre merci monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur claude
dilain comme je lai annoncé dans mon
discours de politique générale une
conférence nationale contre la pauvreté
et pour l'inclusion sociale va se tenir
lundi et mardi prochain et sera en effet
l'occasion d'annoncer les axes
structurants de la politique du
gouvernement en matière de lutte contre
la pauvreté la précarité et les
inégalités dans notre pays et vous avez
raison de souligner l'urgence l'urgence
des situations
qui sont pas des statistiques qui sont
d'abord des visages des hommes et des
femmes et vous les connaissez bien qui
parfois sont stigmatisés comme s'il
était déjà coupable alors que les
hasards de la vie n'est pas toujours les
hasards a pu conduire à des chutes et
qui vont parfois jusqu'à l'extrême
pauvreté
face à cette situation qui dure et qui
perdure mais qui s'est aggravée ces dix
dernières années de laisser-faire tant
économique que sociale et qui se sont
traduites par un bond inégalé des
inégalités dans notre pays et donc il
faut faire face il faut faire front
c'est pourquoi il fallait agir dans
l'urgence et vous l'avez rappelé je vous
en remercie dès les six premiers mois le
gouvernement a pris des mesures
je pense à la revalorisation de 25 % de
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire
ça touche directement les familles les
plus modestes les plus pauvres de notre
pays
combien de critiques avons nous entendu
que c'était un cadeau qui était fait que
ces 25 % en augmentation de l'allocation
de rentrée scolaire à être dépensés en
ipad ou autre produits technologiques
c'est méconnaître la situation difficile
des familles
et bien cette décision nous l'avons
prise et elle est allée directement pour
les enfants et en particulier les
enfants les plus pauvres et nous avons
eu raison de le faire
nous avons également débloqué vous
l'avez rappelé une enveloppe de 50
millions d'euros pour l'hébergement
d'urgence
nous avons engagé l'encadrement des
loyers la suppression de la franchise
médicale pour l'aide médicale d'état
là aussi que n'at-on entendu mais je
voudrais et cette conférence que vous
avez évoqué monsieur le sénateur sera
l'occasion de le rappeler solennellement
on ne fera pas reculer
la situation de la pauvreté de
l'exclusion sociale par un discours
moralisateur de stigmatisation
comme si être pauvre était un choix de
vie mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
je le demande à tous des sénateurs de
toutes les sensibilités d'arrêter
d'exploiter la misère mais de se
mobiliser pour la combattre alors sur le
long terme c'est précisément l'objet de
la conférence de la semaine prochaine et
je tiens à souligner devant vous que
celle ci a été préparée minutieusement
sept groupes de travail menés par des
personnalités incontestables qui ont
travaillé tambour battant avec la
concertation la plus exemplaire
impliquant toutes les associations les
collectivités territoriales les
partenaires sociaux et les représentants
des personnes elles mêmes en situation
de précarité qui sont disons associé
étroitement à la préparation de ces
travaux alors les rapports qui vont être
présentés lors de cette conférence
je le sais déjà ce sont de très haute
qualité ils sont exigeants aussi j'en
suis conscient ils le seront pour le
gouvernement ils le seront pour tous les
acteurs de la lutte contre la pauvreté
et l'exclusion sociale
mais ils pourront constituer comme ça a
été le cas la conférence sociale comme
ça a été le cas la conférence en demies
rhône mentale une véritable feuille de
route est en tout cas qui servira de
base pour les décisions que je serai
amené à annoncer à la fin de cette
conférence
je jouais je laisse ce soin évidemment à
cette conférence et au rapporteur
deprijk de présenter leurs
préconisations déjà avec madame marie
arlette carlotti qui est présenté
aujourd'hui au bord du gouvernement mais
aussi tous les autres ministres nous
sommes mobilisés pour des solutions
concrètes
certaines pourront avoir un effet
immédiat d'autres s'inscriront dans le
moyen terme
elle nécessite des réformes mais en tout
cas je voudrais terminer sur un point
j'ai parlé ces derniers temps du nouveau
modèle français et j'ai parlé de la
nécessité de retrouver la compétitivité
pour nos entreprises et pour l'emploi
mais la compétitivité n'est pas
qu'économique
elle est sociale et
ce nouveau modèle français il n'aura de
sens il sera mobilisateur il redonnera
confiance que s'ils s'appuient sur les
valeurs qui fondent le pacte républicain
et aujourd'hui vous le savez mieux que
quiconque monsieur le sénateur dit l'un
une partie des français ne croient plus
à ces valeurs ne croit plus à ce pack
ils ont perdu confiance tout le défi que
nous avons à le relever c'est de leur
donner toute la place leur place dans la
république
quel que soit l'endroit où ils habitent
qu'ils habitent dans les centres villes
dans les banlieues dans les périphéries
dans les périphéries urbaines ou dans
les quartiers les plus éloignés ou dans
les territoires ruraux
ils ont tous leur place dans la
république le nouveau modèle français
c'est notre mission il demande beaucoup
de travail beaucoup de courage beaucoup
de détermination
le gouvernement là mais il l'a avec
l'appui de la majorité parlementaire que
je tiens à saluer et remercier
merci la parole et à madame 1 aline
archimbaud pour le groupe écologiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame carlotti
ministre chargé des personnes
handicapées et de la lutte contre
l'exclusion
le premier rapport de l'observatoire de
l'institut national de la jeunesse de
l'éducation populaire injep concernant
la situation de la jeunesse en france
présenté ce mardi 4 décembre met en
exergue un constat des plus sombres
on assiste à une fragilisation accrue de
la jeunesse de forts risques d'exclusion
et un creusement des inégalités entre
jeunes dans le contexte actuel de crise
économique dont ils sont les premières
victimes
15% des jeunes ne sont ni en études ni
en formation ni en emploi le taux de
pauvreté des 18 24 ans atteint en
moyenne 22 5% au total plus d'un million
de jeunes sont désormais confrontés à
une situation de grande précarité
le rapport montre également que les
jeunes représentent 22 % de la
population active mais 40% des chômeurs
et que l'augmentation du chômage de
longue durée est particulièrement
préoccupante chez eux
par ailleurs la réalité n'est pas
uniforme le clivage se creuse dans
l'accès à l'emploi entre diplôme
et et non diplômés le taux de chômage
des jeunes non diplômés et de 46 % et 30
% d'entre eux vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté
je voudrais vous alerter sur le
dispositif du rsa jeunes
qui est il faut le constater un échec
total
doté pour 2013 d'un crédit de 27
millions la prévision a été fortement
revu à la baisse du fait de l'important
taux de non recours puisque seuls 8000
jeunes sur les 130 milles initialement
prévu en bénéficient soit 6% et donc un
taux de non recours est de 94%
en effet les conditions requises pour y
avoir droit sont totalement irréalistes
il est exigé que les jeunes justifie
d'une activité professionnelle de deux
ans à temps plein sur les trois années
précédant la demande
quand on connaît la réalité on comprend
qu'il y ait si peu de candidats nous
nous réjouissons de la mise en place des
cent cinquante mille emplois d'avenir
mais beaucoup reste à faire ma question
madame la ministre est donc la suivante
quelle réforme du rsa jeunes
envisagez-vous et que comptez vous faire
pour lutter contre la précarité et la
paupérisation croissante et massive de
la jeunesse
parmi les points qui me semble important
de discuter lors de la conférence
organisée par le gouvernement la semaine
prochaine
avez-vous notamment prévu d'aborder
concernant la jeunesse en situation de
précarité
premièrement la possibilité de mettre en
place une allocation jeunesse donner un
minimum d'autonomie et de stabilité pour
construire un projet deuxièmement
l'impulsion d'une aide forte pour
l'accès à la mobilité au logement et à
la santé
troisièmement et enfin le droit à la
formation
il est urgent de réfléchir à la mise en
place pour les jeunes précaires d'un
droit de tirage automatique à des
formations de qualité dans des filières
d'avenir
tous les acteurs de l'insertion les
missions locales les mouvements
d'éducation populaire insiste sur ce
point tant on connaît les très grandes
difficultés
ou plutôt la quasi impossibilité pour un
jeune qui enchaîne les contrats de
travail très court les stages non
rémunérés et les périodes de chômage à
avoir accès à de telles formations qui
sont pourtant une condition
incontournable
le chômage la jeunesse et l'avenir notre
pays c'est un immense merci merci la
parole est à madame marie arlette
carlotti ministre chargé des personnes
handicapées de la lutte contre
l'exclusion
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice aline archimbaud tous les
rapports sur la jeunesse sont alarmants
vous avez raison de souligner nous le
voyons tous et nous le voyons tous les
jours les jeunes sont durement frappés
par la misère par le chômage l'avenir
devrait pourtant leur appartenir
c'est le résultat non seulement de la
crise mais aussi de politiques et de
dispositifs qui ne se sont pas révélés
totalement adapté à la situation et aux
besoins des jeunes
c'est chez les jeunes que les inégalités
sont les plus marqués il y a des jeunes
qui aujourd'hui n'ont rien ni emploi ni
formation ni ressources
c'est vers eux que nous devons nous
tourner et en priorité
vous ne serez pas digne d'un pays comme
la france de laisser tomber une partie
importante de sa jeunesse et nous devons
donner une seconde chance à ceux qui ont
décroché
vous le savez la jeunesse c'est la
priorité du mandat de françois hollande
c'est la priorité du gouvernement de
jean marc et aux héros la première
mesure que vous avez voté ici même
d'ailleurs ces sont les emplois d'avenir
qui répondent à cette urgence à ces
jeunes sans qualification qui ont besoin
qu'on les aide pour démarrer dans la vie
professionnelle
le contrat de génération sera lui aussi
un levier très puissant pour favoriser
l'emploi des jeunes
mais nous n'en resterons pas là nous
devons aussi être solidaire avec tous
ceux qui ne peuvent pas rentrer tout de
suite sur le marché du travail ou
l'évoquiez tout à l'heure madame la
sénatrice le rsa jeunes est en effet un
échec
il n'est pas adapté au public auquel il
était au départ destinée l'obtenir
aujourd'hui c'est une mission impossible
il n'est lié à aucune mesure
d'accompagnement qui aurait permis aux
jeunes de retourner vers le chemin de
l'emploi vous le signaler également
seuls 900 mille neuf mille pardons parce
que c'était au départ 130000 qui était
visé aujourd'hui on est à 9000 jeunes
qui ont recours seulement aujourd'hui
nous devons tenir compte de cet échec et
nous devons il est de notre
responsabilité de trop
v de nouvelles façons de soutenir les
jeunes en difficulté ceux qui n'ont ni
formation ni emploi et je crois que ce
sera l'un des grands objectifs de la
conférence dont a parlé le premier
ministre à l'instant merci merci la
parole est à présent monsieur pierre
laurent pour le groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
depuis hier vous vous acharnez à
défendre l'accord passé entre votre
gouvernement et mittal ou non d'un
argument vous sauver l'emploi
bon la droite vous êtes disqualifié sur
ce sujet donc laissez moi parler mais
vous ne parvenez pas mais vous ne
parvenez pas à convaincre
en effet comment garantir l'emploi si
l'avenir industriel de florange lui ne
l'est pas déjà là l'arrêt des hauts
fourneaux de florange prive la région
sont pour de son poumon économique et
menace de destruction des centaines
d'emplois directs indirects et
intérimaires mais surtout alors qu'hier
encore à l'assemblée nationale vous
déclariez avoir obtenu là à la reprise
du projet ulcos ce mittal vient de
donner le coup de grâce à florange en
retirant la candidature du site de
l'appel d'offres européen
monsieur mittal n'a en vérité jamais
renoncer à son plan de dépeçage de
l'industrie sidérurgique notamment de sa
filière chaude en europe le groupe
arcelormittal profite des aides
publiques mais organise les pertes de
rentabilité des sites pour les
fragiliser afin de justifier leur
fermeture
il y a donc deux visions radicalement
différente en présence d'un côté celle
de mittal qui organise le déclin de
l'industrie en cherchant à préserver ses
intérêts financiers
de l'autre côté celles avancées par les
syndicalistes par de nombreux élus du
territoire lorrain mais aussi par le
rapport fort commandé par votre
gouvernement qui préconise des
investissements importants sur le site
dans le cadre d'une option nationale
pour la sidérurgie
pourquoi avoir enterré si vite ce
rapport officiel monsieur le premier
ministre entre ces deux visions vous
devez choisir laisser la main amicale
s'est tourné le dos aux salariés au
projet
causse à l'intérêt de la france si vous
choisi soisy c'est l'intérêt national
ce qu'évidemment nous vous demandons
vous devez ouvrir le dossier
les prétendus engagement de mittal qu'il
a déjà travaillé en quelques heures
nos peuvent en aucun cas mettre un point
final au dossier de florange
j'ai donc trois questions à vous poser
premièrement quelles garanties
pouvez-vous donner pour un engagement
rapide et finances et du projet ulcos ce
deuxièmement le gouvernement s'engage
t-il à ouvrir sans délai le dossier de
l'avenir industriel du site de florange
et plus largement des sites
d'arcelormittal en france y compris en
examinant la voie de la nationalisation
troisièmement puisque vous avez annoncé
la mise en place d'un comité de suivi
etes-vous prêts en ouvrant sa
composition à une représentation
pluraliste des élus locaux et des
parlementaires à élargir sa mission pour
construire les solutions industrielles
d'avenir qui font toujours défaut à
l'heure qu'il est merci monsieur jean
marc ayrault au premier ministre merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
et sénateurs messieurs les sénateurs
pierre laurent j'ai écouté avec beaucoup
d'attention votre question et en
particulier j'ai été très attentif à
votre conclusion qui interpelle le
gouvernement sur sa volonté de donner et
de permettre à la lorraine des
perspectives d'avenir
je comprends très bien cette question et
croyez bien que en tant que chef de
gouvernement j'y suis particulièrement
attentifs hier soir j'ai rencontré
l'intersyndicale de florange avec des
responsables des fédérations de la
métallurgie qui les accompagnait c'était
une rencontre d'une grande franchise et
d'un grand respect mutuel et chacun a
exprimé son point de vue c'est ce que
nous souhaitions les uns et les autres
et j'ai expliqué les raisons du choix du
gouvernement et ce midi j'ai rencontré
les élus
du conseil régional de lorraine mais
aussi de départements du département est
également des maires et des présidents
d'intercommunalités et quelques
parlementaires de sensibilités
différentes
en tout cas ceux qui avaient accepté de
venir là aussi nous sommes parlé
franchement le gouvernement et le
président de la république lui avait
fixé ce mandat pas de plan social à
florange pas de suppressions d'emplois
pas de licenciements à florange cet
objectif il a été atteint ça a été le
fruit des négociations que le
gouvernement engagé la semaine dernière
avec mittal négociations difficiles
précédé d'une rencontre entre monsieur
mittal et le président de la république
deuxième objectif obtenir un engagement
de d'investissement de financement
d'investissements sur la partie froid et
la partie emballages de 180 millions
d'euros
c'est un vrai engagement a été acceptée
alors maintenant il s'agit évidemment de
veiller à ce que ces investissements
soient respectés et soient tenus
il en va de même également pour le
projet ulcos vous dites que le groupe
mittal a porté un coup de grâce nom n'a
pas porté de coups de grâce il n'a fait
dit il n'a dit que ce qui avait été dit
clairement dans la négociation vous avez
fait allusion aux rapports qui avait été
commandé par le gouvernement à monsieur
pascal faure
ce rapport relevait que le projet ulcos
ce tel qu'il avait été étudiée à ce
stade ne permettait pas de développer un
processus industriel compte tenu des
difficultés techniques qu'il
représentait donc c'est d'un commun
accord que nous avons constaté en effet
que le projet s'il restait en l'état
mettait en péril l'avenir du projet
ulcos ce le projet ulcos ce je le
rappelle c'est un projet industriel
innovant qui a pour objectif de produire
de l'acier
sans pour autant rejeter dans
l'atmosphère autant de co2 que les
processus habituels le fond
ce qui est un vrai problème dans un pays
comme le nôtre qui est confrontée aux
grands défis de la transition
énergétique
c'est un projet qui a pour objectif la
captation du co2 certes je sais qu'il ya
des gens qui sont contre qui préférait
qu'il y ait plus de co2 du tout enfin
moi je suis partisan d'une aide un
avenir industriel à la france est donc
une industrie qui soit capable justement
même si elle produit du co2 de ne pas je
dirais le transport préféré dans
l'atmosphère donc c'est un projet
innovant
c'est un projet d'avenir mais qui
unissait qui nécessitent en effet pour
réussir et bien beaucoup
d'investissement et en particulier en
recherche développement
donc ce qui a été dit par mittal à la
commission européenne
c'est que ce projet va être repris et le
gouvernement y est associée il y à déjà
150 millions d'euros qui sont réservées
au titre des investissements d'avenir et
qui sont gérés par le commissariat
général à l'investissement qui est
dirigé par louis gallois qui est placée
auprès du premier ministre donc pensez
bien que ces 150 millions réservés pour
ce projet
j'ai tout à fait l'intention qu'ils
soient utilisés j'ai d'ailleurs demandé
à madame la ministre
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
geneviève fioraso qui est également
présente au banc du gouvernement de
réunir immédiatement tous les
laboratoires de recherche intéressés et
ils sont nombreux pour justement
remettre à plat le volet recherche et ce
qui est fait et donc nous allons agir
dans cette direction la lorraine a le
droit à un avenir comme toutes les
autres régions françaises
donc oui il ya une différence peut-être
avec ce qui s'était fait avant c'est que
dans les engagements qui ont été pris
par mittal dans la négociation de la
semaine dernière il n'y a aucune
condition et pour nous c'était un
préalable
lorsque vous aviez vous mesdames et
messieurs de la majorité en tous cas le
gouvernement prétendu que des
engagements avaient été pris il était
conditionnée à une meilleure conjoncture
sur le plan du marché de l'acier
eh bien il n'y a aucune condition alors
monsieur le sénateur pierre laurent vous
pourriez me dire oui mais est ce que ces
engagements vont être tenues
c'est une question légitime c'est pour
ça que
j'ai désigné le sous préfet monsieur
matte pratique est actuellement sous
préfet de lorraine
l'afer est suffisamment sérieuse et
grave pour éviter les réactions un peu
simpliste et qui demande sans doute de
votre part mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs de la majorité
un peu de modestie et de respect face à
une région qui souffre et qui
s'inquiètent
j'ai demandé à ceux sous préfet qui va
dans quelques jours être totalement
disponible puisqu'il va terminer son
mandat
à thionville de se consacrer totalement
à la direction d'un comité de suivi qui
disposera des moyens de l'état en
particulier un expert qui sera chargé du
projet ulcos ce un autre qui sera chargé
de suivre les investissements et qui
associera tous les partenaires vous avez
parlé des élus monsieur pierre laurent
ils me l'ont demandé aussi les élus
locaux les parlementaires comme dans
beaucoup de territoires lorsqu'un
programme graves se posent un problème
de d'avenir industriels les préfets
organisent des tables rondes et bien là
c'est une table ronde permanente que
nous souhaitons organiser avec les
partenaires sociaux et j'espère que tout
ça pourra rapidement se mettre en oeuvre
en tout cas je recevrai ce soir le
sous-préfet maserati pour lui fixé sa
feuille de route et j'ai indiqué au
président du conseil régional de
lorraine que le gouvernement était prêt
à négocier avec lui et l'ensemble des
élus des territoires
un contrat d'objectifs ambitieux qui au
delà du respect des engagements qui ont
été pris par mittal de prendre à bras le
corps tous les autres dossiers
industriels environnementaux sociaux
pour permettre à la lorraine qui est une
région qui comme le nord pas de calais
et d'autres régions de france a
particulièrement souffert de toutes les
restructurations industrielles à la fois
la crise minière à la fois la crise
sidérurgique
mais qui a droit peut-être encore plus
que d'autres au soutien de l'état et je
n'ai pas le droit parce que c'est ma
conception de la politique de faire
croire que en appuyant sur un bouton les
recettes magiques
se développe monsieur le sénateur pierre
laurent vous avez évoqué les
perspectives de nationalisation
moi je n'ai aucun sujet tabou les
participations publiques l'état en a
prises et il en prendra dans ce dossier
il aurait pu en prendre et il aura
prendra de toute façon dans beaucoup
d'autres mais ce que je ne voudrais pas
qu'on croit c'est parce qu'on dit mot
nationalisation
ça veut dire que tout est réglé et j'ai
trop de souvenirs que j'ai pas vécu
personnellement je n'étais pas encore
parlementaire mais j'ai trop de
souvenirs politiques et en tout cas les
populations concernées l'ont aussi
lorsqu'il ya eu la nationalisation de la
sidérurgie
il y à une restructuration il ya eu
trente mille emplois de supprimer moi je
me bats pour l'emploi je me bats pour la
compétitivité
je me bats pour l'avenir industriel mais
mon devoir c'est de dire la vérité et
dire la vérité c'est respecter les gens
et donc ce qui a été négocié
c'est parce que le gouvernement en
conscience a considéré que c'était la
meilleure solution
pas de plan social préservation de
l'emploi investissements industriels
préparation de l'avenir
et aujourd'hui je le confirme soutien à
l'avenir d'une région contractualisation
avec la région lorraine
voilà la position du gouvernement c'est
une position de franchise de respect et
je crois que c'est aussi celle du
courage merci la parole et à monsieur
jean pierre plancade pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique social
européen
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur les ministres
affaires étrangères et concerne les
dernières évolutions du confirmé en
syrie monsieur le ministre ces derniers
jours et ces dernières heures plusieurs
informations indiquent que la situation
s'aggrave encore en syrie et que nouveau
palier serait en train d'être franchie
avec l'utilisation d'armes chimiques par
les hommes de bachar al-assad à
l'encontre de la rébellion et du peuple
syrien
hier encore l'artillerie l'aviation
syriennes ont bombardé la périphérie de
damas et des bombes chargé semble-t-il
avec du gaz sarin aurait été larguée sur
les rebelles lundi un responsable
américain a affirmé que damas bélanger
des composants chimiques à la
militarisation du gaz
dans ce même temps le secrétaire général
des nations unies a appelé toutes les
parties à arrêter immédiatement les
combats et à de nouveaux écrits à bachar
al assad pour l'avenir l'avertir et je
cite que l'utilisation d'armes chimiques
serait un crime scandaleux aux
conséquences désastreuses
je voudrais que mes collègues sur la
partie gauche mais qui sont en réalité
de droite se calme un petit peu et
écoute pas respecté les orateurs comme
lui même le fait chaque fois que
quelqu'un de l'opposition le fait
excusez moi monsieur le président de
cette remarque je persiste donc dans le
même temps le secrétaire général des
nations unies a appelé toutes les
parties à arrêter immédiatement les
combats et à de nouveaux écrits à bachar
al assad pour l'avertir je cite que
l'utilisation d'armes chimiques
serait-elle grimm scandaleux aux
conséquences désastreuses
bien évidemment l'otan et les pays
occidentaux dont la france ont condamné
la perspective de voir le régime en
place
utiliser de tels moyens mais si toutes
ces mises en garde sont nécessaires et
indispensables
on est en droit de s'interroger sur leur
efficacité selon les experts le conflit
entrerait dans une phase décisive et la
banlieue de damas est désormais au coeur
des combats son contrôle constitue un
enjeu majeur pour le régime en avant
d'éventuelles négociations vers une
issue semble t-il je rappelle simplement
que ce conflit en 20 mois a fait plus de
quarante et un mille morts
essentiellement des civils des femmes et
des enfants
bachar al assad semble donc décidé à
franchir la ligne rouge
n'at-elle d'ailleurs pas et elle
franchit cette ligne rouge fixée par le
président obama à savoir le recours des
armes de destruction massive contre le
peuple syrien
c'est pourquoi monsieur le ministre
pouvez vous nous informez pour vous
informer excusez-moi la représentation
nationale sur la situation du conflit
syrien et particulièrement sur
l'utilisation récente ou non d'armes
chimiques
que sait-on des stocks d'armes des
sanctions massives dont disposera syrie
stocks essentiellement fournie à
l'époque par l'union soviétique et
l'iran et dont la russie dispose d'une
connaissance précise de leur
localisation dans ces conditions peut-on
encore envisagée ou éviter surtout une
intervention militaire de l'otan en
syrie
si les choses s'accélèrent sur le
terrain il y à t'il aussi une
accélération de la diplomatie
pour parvenir à une issue rapide et à la
chute de ce tyran merci madame hélène
conway mouret ministre chargé des
français de l'étranger
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur jean-pierre plancade je vous
prie d'excuser laurent fabius qui est
absent aujourd'hui les temps de
déplacement à l'étranger
je voudrais vous avez raison monsieur le
sénateur de parler de la syrie
nous sommes aujourd'hui à un tournant de
la crise syrienne les combats s'étendent
désormais à damas dont l'aéroport a été
pour la première fois fermé pendant
trois jours
malgré la répression féroce l'opposition
continue de gagner du terrain
l'opposition souhaite prendre le
contrôle de la capitale ce qui pourrait
entraîner l'effondrement du régime
vous l'avez rappelé alors que l'on
dénombre plus de quarante et un mille
morts on peut craindre que l' approche
de l'hiver va aggraver les souffrances
de la population syrienne déjà
cruellement éprouvée monsieur le
sénateur vous avez soulevé la question
de l'utilisation des armes chimiques
nous devons rester très vigilants alors
que des informations font état de
préparatifs entrepris par le régime en
vue d'une éventuelle utilisation des ces
armes que le régime détient au nombre
important
nous suivons la situation en étroite
collaboration avec nos partenaires
notamment américains qui ont fermement
mis en garde bachar al assad
s'il venait à franchir cette ligne rouge
les informations auxquelles vous faites
allusion quant à la possible mais
militarisation de sarah continue de
faire l'objet de vérifications
notre message est inchangé il est
extrêmement ferme tout emploi de ses
armes chimiques par les autorités
syriennes serait inacceptable et la
communauté internationale ne restera pas
inactive si elle venait à les utiliser
dans ce contexte vous poser la question
d'une intervention de l'otan celle ci
comme vous le savez ne pourrait être
intervenir qu'au titre de l'article 5 du
traité de washington à la demande d'un
allié qui seraient victimes d'une
attaque contre son territoire ou sur la
vase amanda qui ne peut venir que du
conseil de sécurité
c'est dans le cadre de cette légalité
internationale que nous devons agir
comme on a eu l'occasion comme a eu
l'occasion de le rappeler laurent fabius
je veux souligner ici que le déploiement
de missiles patriot à la frontière entre
la turquie et la syrie n'obéit qu'à une
stricte
logique défensive et ne préfigure en
rien une hypothétique intervention de
l'alliance atlantique
sur le plan diplomatique enfin la france
reste fortement engagé auprès de
l'opposition syrienne pour rappeler que
la france est pionnière dans l'ue
l'appui aux comités révolutionnaires
locaux
elle a aussi été la première à
reconnaître la coalition syrienne comme
seul représentant légitime du peuple
syrien
certains de nos partenaires se sont
depuis rallié à cette position
l'anf abuse participera le 12 décembre à
la réunion des amis du peuple syrien à
marrakech pour réaffirmer l'engagement
de la france aux côtés du peuple syrien
nous espérons que l'ensemble du groupe
des amis reconnaîtra à cette occasion la
coalition pour conforter sa légitimité
et sa crédibilité
la perspective d'un gouvernement
provisoire se rapproche nous espérons
qu'une série lui une syrie libre et
démocratique émergera de ces évolutions
merci la parole et à monsieur françois
grosdidier pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
qui vient courageusement de s'éclipser
le gouvernement a conclu un accord avec
mittal qui sonne le glas de la filière
chaude à florange il avait pourtant
déclaré mittal indésirable en france
il a même effrayer les investisseurs
étrangers en brandissant l'armé suprême
de la nationalisation
tout cela pour finalement capituler pas
même la vente des hauts fourneaux que
mittal était d'accord de céder après
avoir vilipendé nicolas sarkozy le
gouvernement obtenus - que lui et perd
sur les deux tableaux pour masquer les
zones dont de cet accord le premier
ministre a multiplié les contre vérités
j'en ai rêvé relevé cinq qui pose
question il dit que nicolas sarkozy
avait promis de sauver gandrange faut il
avait dit j étais qu'il essaierait de
faire changer d'avis mittal cas des
poules il soutiendra plan de reprise et
qu'à défaut de plan de reprise il y
aurait zéro licenciement et des mesures
de compensation
cela a été fait mais avait voulu
seulement le verbatim 2 le premier
ministre a dit qu'il n'y aurait pas de
suppression d'emplois faut il oublie les
sous traitants et pour mittal il confond
délibérément suppressions d'emplois et
licenciements secs
c'est plus de 600 emplois qui sont
condamnés et pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de ces restructurations sans
prévoir aucun emploi de substitution par
deux fois hier monsieur ayrault a fait
cette remarque cynique que les autres
régions envier à la lorraine
ces dispositifs sociaux la lorraine a
perdu en une génération
cent mille emplois directs dans les
houillères et la sidérurgie
trouvez-vous ce sort enviable par les
autres régions 3
il l'a dit hier soir qu'il est optimiste
pour une cause ce matin on apprend le
retrait dulko ce n'était pas au courant
4 il a dit avoir obtenu 180 millions
d'euros d'investissements nouveaux faux
si on enlève les investissements de
maintenance il n'y a que 50 millions sur
cinq ans et sans engagement pour 2013
est-ce qu avec si peu et sans lui cause
on peut vraiment pérenniser l'activité
et enfin cinquièmement il a dit que ce
projet de reprise auraient coûté plus
d'un milliard d'euros sans certitude de
viabilité
c'est faux encore même une nouvelle
usine à froid n'aurait coûté que la
moitié avec des débouchés assurés
c'était à la portée des investisseurs
candidat repreneur avec un amendement du
fsi moins cher qu'une nationalisation et
je parle pas des 150 millions qui
étaient prévus pour hulk hausse et que
vous êtres rebasculer sur ce projet
alors pourquoi avez-vous écarté ce
projet de reprise est confortée le
quasi-monopole de mittal en france merci
monsieur alain vidalis ministre chargé
des relations avec le parlement
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur je vous remercie de
votre question extrêmement nuancé et je
vous remercie surtout d'avoir rappelé en
toute objectivité et que ce problème
tiré d'un territoire et ce problème
industriel n'était pas apparue avec le
gouvernement socialiste et l'élection de
françois hollande et que ça fait 18 mois
ça fait 18 mois que les hauts fourneaux
sont fermés et donc je vous ai entendu
je vous ai entendu élaboré ici une sorte
de solution miracle
d'évidence sur ce qu'il aurait fallu
faire
et il m'est venue cette question
saugrenue mais pourquoi ne l'avez vous
pas fait avant pourquoi pendant les 12
mois au moins pendant lequel les hauts
fourneaux était arrêté vous n'avez rien
fait ou probablement vous n'avez pas été
entendu alors vous évoquez l'action de
nicolas sarkozy et vous dit vous n'avez
rien obtenu de plus je voudrais juste un
peu nuancer cette approche
d'abord il suffit de se rappeler qu'elle
a été le communiqué de presse lorsque le
candidat que vous souteniez était venu
sur le terrain pour annoncer le résultat
merveilleux qu'elle est aboutir au
sauvetage et à l'avenir assurer pour
florange
ça se passe au mois de mars pendant la
campagne électorale il ya un communiqué
ian investissement financier extrêmement
important qui semblait vous satisfaire à
l'époque 17 millions aujourd'hui 180
millions on voit le ridicule de la
situation vous en est réduit à dire ah
oui mais c'était 17 millions de suite
dont 17 millions qui allait sauver
florange aujourd'hui 180 millions
deuxièmement lorsqu'on regarde le
communiqué de l'époque lorsque le
candidat président vient il fait cette
annonce est immédiatement
arcelormittal en mai c'est conditionné
peut-être si la filière s'améliore si
les circonstances économiques
s'améliorent c'est exactement le
contraire de ce qui a été négocié par ce
gouvernement qui rentrait dans le débat
en disant nous voulons un plan mais qui
ne soit pas conditionnée à des aléas
économiques
c'est une nuance dans tous les cas une
différence majeure
et puis vous dit ce qui est quand même
assez étonnant que il n'y avait pas de
plan social et qui n'y aurait aucun
licenciement et bien c'est totalement
faux je vous renvoie au communiqué
puisqu'à l'époque probablement espérant
une réélection
votre candidat lui expliquer qu avait 17
millions ils allaient sauver vous
énervez pas assez dure la vérité quand
on la rappelle assez dur et oui sauf que
j'ai là la dépêche où on explique qu
avait ses 17 millions
on va on va éviter 500 licenciements et
voilà-t-il pas que vous quelques mois
après vous dites qu'il n'y avait aucun
licenciement prévu
que ça vous plaise ou non le
gouvernement à négocier avec les trois
objectifs qu'a rappelé le premier
ministre
premièrement éviter les licenciements et
il n'y aura pas de licenciements
contrairement à ce que vous nous avez
laissé comme héritage faire des
investissements 180 millions et non pas
10 7 millions et puis enfin le premier
ministre vous a déjà répondu sur le
projet ulcos ce vous pouvez au moins
regarder non pas le communiqué du
gouvernement mais celui d' arcelormittal
qui a été publiée ce matin et qui
explique que le retrait du dossier à la
commission est exactement l'application
de l'accord puisque le dossier disons
ulcos ce1 ne répondait pas à ses
objectifs et que grâce à
l'investissement et notamment des 150
millions mis par le gouvernement et bien
il y aura un dossier ulcos ce qui va
s'inscrire au surpluss dans ce qui est
le projet qui devrait normalement vous
mobiliser comme élu de la lorraine
c'est à dire donner à cette région qui
le méritent des perspectives d'avenir
est aussi donnée aux salariés qui se
sont beaucoup battus y compris pour
qu'on en arrive à cette solution
satisfaisante lors donner un la
possibilité de contrôler le respect par
mittal de ses engagements et c'est ce
qui a été annoncé avec le comité de
suivi et deuxièmement ce qui a été
décidé à midi un contrat de
développement industriel pour la
lorraine
c'est probablement un détail qui nous a
échappé dans la réponse du premier
ministre mais je pense que pour les
salariés les habitants et les élus de la
lorraine
c'est bien c'est bien c'est bien la
définition de cet objectif industriel
pour la lorraine qui est le plus
important aux débats de petits débats
partisans
merci madame valérie létard pour le
groupe union des démocrates et
indépendants us et si monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame marie
arlette carlotti ministre délégué en
charge des personnes handicapées
madame la ministre le sénat a choisi
d'organiser aujourd'hui un colloque sur
l'autisme en cette année de grandes
causes nationales
je vous rappelle que la réalité de
l'autisme et des troubles envahissants
du développement touche 350 à 600 mille
personnes adultes et enfants dans notre
pays c'est à dire que c'est loin d'être
anecdotique c'est un sujet qui touche
pratiquement autant de personnes que la
question d'alzheimer un taux de
prévalence de 1 enfant sur 150
un enfant sur 150 nés atteints de
handicap vous avez annoncé madame la
ministre
trois axes de travail pour le 3ème futur
plan autisme la recherche
le parcours de vie la sensibilisation et
la formation sur ces trois axes la
nouvelle phase de concertation que vous
avez engagé a généré en même temps d
attente mais aussi des inquiétudes des
familles au travers de l'impatience que
ces associations voient elles
souhaiteraient être associés plus en
amont à sont hélas de son élaboration
mais surtout aussi un démarrage rapide
de ce nouveau plan madame la ministre
le bilan du plan précédent existe le
diagnostic a été posé sur la base des
avancées mais aussi de ses insuffisances
en matière de formation par exemple
tout n'est pas qu'une question de moyens
financiers il s'agit surtout par exemple
de réorienter notre système de formation
pour former prioritairement les
professionnels qualifiés en intégrant
les nouvelles méthodes attendue depuis
longtemps par les familles ces méthodes
étant absente les familles partent en
belgique
bourque pourquoi pour avoir la prise en
charge que nous devrions être en
capacité d'apporter ce sujet n'est pas
simple mais il est attendu il est une
mais les familles en détresse
il laisse des familles complètement à
l'abandon face à face un véritable sujet
de société
pour cela il va falloir d'abord un
portage politique fort ou plus haut
niveau comme celui engagé pour le plan
alzheimer que je citais tout à l'heure
madame la ministre
suite à la grande cause alzheimer c'est
ce qu'avait été fait donc madame la
ministre pouvait vous transmettre
aujourd'hui notre requête au président
de la république requête partager très
largement par les défenseurs de cette
cause et ses acteurs est il prêt est ce
que monsieur le président de la
république pourrait être prêt à lancer
orthez est à suivre à son niveau un plan
autisme tout comme le plan alzheimer
l'avait été par son prédécesseur
c'est à dire une fois tous les trois
mois rendre compte devant l'elysée et
bien simplement des avancées que tous
les ministères doivent être en capacité
de mettre en oeuvre pour accompagner
quelque chose qui touche à tous ses
composants
tous les ministères ont un sujet à
traiter et à régler sur cette question
de l'autisme que l'on soit l'éducation
nationale la recherche que l'on soit
effectivement dans les domaines de la
santé ou du médico social
tous nous sommes concernés par cette
question si madame ariane carlotti
ministre chargé des personnes
handicapées de la lutte contre
l'exclusion
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice valérie létard effectivement
nous en parlions ce matin ensemble dans
un colloque ici même au sénat le sénat
qui s'est très engagée sur cette
question sur la question du handicap
d'une manière générale sur cette
question en particulier je remercie
d'ailleurs cet hémicycle et les
sénateurs et sénatrices de ces d'être si
porté par ces questions et si vraiment
volontariste nous en parlions donc et
l'autisme est un handicap qu'on a trop
longtemps gardé sous silence
nous devons mieux le faire connaître
mieux en parler pour qu'il soit mieux
acceptés dans notre société madame
létard je connais votre engagement en
faveur des personnes avec autisme et
auprès auprès de leurs familles l'année
2012 a vu l'autisme consacré grande
cause nationale
l'année 2013 verra la mise en place du
3e plan autisme qui me revient
effectivement de préparer au moment où
je parle
nous devons aborder sereinement les
enjeux de la prise en charge des
personnes avec autisme et laisser tout
place à la concertation en particulier
avec les familles qui connaissent le
handicap de très très près qui en
souffrent je suis venu leur dire ce
matin la concertation à la fois se baser
sur les plans précédents qui ont apporté
des choses en tirer les conséquences qui
va pas ce qui va bien mais faire
véritablement un vrai travail avec elle
je me suis engagé tout à l'heure ce
matin devant vous auprès d'elle pour que
nous le fassions tous ensemble pour
élaborer ce troisième plan autisme
j'ai réuni dès le mois de juillet le
comité national de l'autisme j'ai
demandé à la députée madame martine
pinville de piloter les groupes de
travail chargés de préparer ce plan le
comité national travaille sur trois axes
comme je les dis comme vous voulez
répéter un la recherche de la formation
3 le développement d'une offre
d'accompagnement pour les enfants pour
les adolescents mais aussi pour les
adultes parce qu'on a une énorme manque
dans ce domaine je veux un renforcer la
recherche en dans le champ
épidémiologique le champ cliniques et
dans le champ social car nous ne
connaissons toujours pas la population
réellement touchés par les troubles
autistes nous ignorons pourquoi la
prévalence augmente
au moment où nous parlons vous citiez le
nombre d'enfants atteints par ce trouble
nous avons besoin d'évaluer les
bénéfices procurés par les différentes
méthodes et nous le ferons sans
exclusive et dans la pacification du
débat nous devons former les
professionnels vous le disiez à une
meilleure prise en charge de l'autisme
c'est mon deuxième axe mais nous devons
également toujours dans cet axe la
diffuser des connaissances que nous
avons sur l'autisme à l'ensemble de la
population pour faire une société plus
accueillante et plus tolérante celle que
nous voulons construire et je veux enfin
dans un troisième acte ce plan que ce
soit l'occasion d'améliorer la
continuité des parcours les parcours les
ruptures pour les autistes sont
terriblement pénalisante
l'offre de soins devraient être
développés devraient être coordonnées
avion afin de mieux répondre aux besoins
des personnes prises en charge
le détail du plan sera annoncé par le
gouvernement dès 2013 dès le début après
donc toutes les consultations d'usagé en
particulier du comité national de
l'autisme le gouvernement de jean marc
ayrault est à l'écouté de tous ceux qui
sont les parents les familles les
associations les médecins et qui vivent
l'autisme au quotidien nous nous
appuierons sur leur expertise pour
dessiner les solutions de demain et nous
permettront ainsi aux enfants et aux
adultes de retrouver un peu le sourire
quant à la façon dont ça sera portée
sachez que ça sera porté par le premier
ministre dans un comité interministériel
du handicap dans lequel l'autisme aura
toute sa place car en effet ça concerne
l'ensemble des ministres de notre
gouvernement
merci la parole est à monsieur maurice
antiste pour le groupe socialiste et
apparentés
ma question s'adresse au ministre chargé
la formation professionnelle et de
l'apprentissage
elle porte sur la problématique des
études en alternance qui s'avère de plus
en plus difficile pour les jeunes
souhaitant poursuivre leur cursus mais
qui se retrouvent contré par la force
des choses d'y renoncer
en effet le problème du chômage des
jeunes est très présent en europe comme
l'a rappelé la commission européenne en
septembre dernier à l'occasion de la
publication de rapports sur la jeunesse
relevant que ce chômage les expose à un
risque de pauvreté d'exclusion sociale
en france
trois ans après leur sortie du système
scolaire
40% des jeunes sans diplôme sont au
chômage contre 9% pour les jeunes
diplômés du supérieur
je sais monsieur le ministre que le
gouvernement a pris en compte cette
donnée préoccupante puisque vous tentez
de mettre en place une véritable
politique en faveur de l'emploi des
jeunes au travers notamment du
développement des formations en
alternance
c'est ainsi que le premier ministre dans
son allocution portant sur le pacte
national pour la croissance la
compétitivité l'emploi a donné comme
objectif de porter à 500 mille le nombre
d'apprentis à l'horizon 2017 je me
félicite de cette politique ambitieuse
qui demande que l'alternance constitue
un outil indispensable est intéressant
pour l'insertion des jeunes dans la vie
professionnelle en leur permettant de
poursuivre une formation qualifiante ce
qui constitue dès lors un véritable
passeport pour l'emploi en france
l'alternance permet au final dans huit
cas sur dix d'obtenir un emploi pérenne
et l'apprentissage augmentent en moyenne
de 7 points les chances d'un jeune
d'être en emploi
malgré ce constat les entreprises
françaises sont peu disposés à miser sur
des jeunes non qualifiés et à leur
proposer des parcours de
professionnalisation
alors même qu'il y en france un
véritable potentiel de développement de
l'apprentissage que le secteur public
comme privés pourraient mieux exploiter
en martinique et plus généralement aux
antilles et guyane
il faut savoir que 62 % des jeunes de
moins de 25 ans sont au chômage
parmi ceux ci se trouvent grand nombre
de jeunes bacheliers qui veulent
continuer leurs études en alternance
mais qui sont contre et d'y renoncer
faute d'une volonté des entreprises de
les accueillir et eu égard à la
situation économique et au marché de
l'emploi très difficile un jeune dans
cette situation devient par la force des
choses un nouveau chômeur c'est pourquoi
je souhaite savoir monsieur le ministre
quelle magie on peut prendre le
gouvernement pour inciter les
entreprises à accueillir beaucoup plus
et plus facilement les jeunes demandeurs
qui veulent suivre une formation en
alternance exquis ces jours-ci période
limite d'inscription sont proches du
désespoir
ainsi que leurs parents merci monsieur
thierry repentin ministre chargée de la
formation professionnelle et de
l'apprentissage
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur en tice mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs 48 heures après un débat
qui s'est tenu dans ce même hémicycle
sur l'emploi la formation et l'insertion
professionnelle des jeunes je vous
remercie de me donner la possibilité de
dire quelles sont les actions mises en
place par le gouvernement pour favoriser
effectivement les jeunes vers l'emploi
sans tirer de conclusions définitives
puisque nous ne sommes qu'au début du
mois de novembre qui lit encore le mois
de décembre ce que je peux vous indiquer
c'est que la baisse des contrats en
alternance qui nous était indiqué en
début d'année prochaine ne sera pas au
rendez-vous en effet au mois de octobre
après les dix premiers mois nous sommes
sur une croissance du nombre de contrats
d'apprentissage en france de 8%
d'augmentation
même si dans le département de la
martinique effectivement nous avons à
connaître une baisse mais le département
de la martinique
au contraire est beaucoup plus dynamique
sur les contrats en alternance au delà
des contrats d'apprentissage
ce résultat global au niveau de la
nation favorable il faut le dire il est
remarquable dans une situation de crise
économique
les tpe les petites entreprises mais
également les moyennes entreprises
montre en prenant plus d'apprentis dans
leur effectif qu'ils ont confiance
ils ont de l'espoir dans l'avenir et
nous allons conforter par un certain
nombre de dispositions l'apprentissage
et le fait de prendre effectivement des
jeunes dans l'entreprise
ceci étant monsieur le sénateur je
comprends votre inquiétude est légitime
car de nombreux jeunes ne trouvent pas
suffisamment de place dans les
entreprises
alors même que des métiers sont en
tension vous le savez le gouvernement
s'est fixé l'objectif de passer de 400
milles à 500000 apprentis d'ici la fin
de ce quinquennat ovules de les
désactiver aujourd'hui cet objectif est
crédible nous devrons développeront donc
l'apprentissage dans trois directions
dans les secteurs où il est peu utilisé
je veux citer l'économie sociale les
secteurs des collectivités locales de la
fonction publique et certaines branches
professionnelles mais également faire
évoluer les différentes aides allouées
aux entreprises pour favoriser les
contrats d'apprentissage et accompagner
les jeunes car vous avez raison certains
jeunes issus de territoires défavorisés
n'accèdent pas spontanément à
l'apprentissage cela
ces mesures se rajouteront effectivement
aux cent cinquante mille emplois
d'avenir que je signe partout sur le
territoire national mais également les
contrats de génération que vous aurez à
voter au printemps prochain
ce sont là des exemples très concrets de
la volonté de ce gouvernement de faire
de la jeunesse et de l'emploi
sa première priorité aidé par cela par
la majorité parlementaire
merci la parole est à monsieur alain
dufaut pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à cécile duflot ministre de
l'égalité des territoires et du logement
madame la ministre dans un entretien au
parisien lundi vous avez en quelque
sorte stigmatiser l'église catholique en
évoquant la réquisition de locaux quasi
vide leur appartenant afin d'abriter les
sdf mais heureusement la crème des
inventaires et loin et personne ne
demandera l'ouverture les tabernacles
comme une circulaire de 1906 le film
prix d'avant
après le vote de la loi de séparation
des églises et de l'état
mal vous en a pris si je veux dire au vu
des réactions que vos propos ont soulevé
de toutes parts et je dis bien de toute
part vouloir faire accréditer que dans
ce domaine là les églises puisque tout
se sentent concernés n'en faisait pas
assez relève de la politique
politicienne et ne saurait avoir cours
sur le sujet
cela vous a été reprochée vous vous
trompez d'adressent madame la ministre
vouloir faire de la politique de cette
manière envers et contre tous quand il
s'agit de solidarité de générosité de
bénévolat n'est pas convenable madame le
peuple français tout entier solidaire de
ces populations en grande difficulté il
le montre bien
et mettre en doute la mobilisation
depuis toujours de l'église et de ses
dizaines de milliers de bénévoles envers
les plus démunis
plus spécialement depuis l'abbé pierre
dans l'époque moderne pour les loger les
entoure et s'occuper d'eux c'est avoir
recours à la manipulation
celle du bouc émissaire qui comme le dit
la définition permet au groupe de se
laver symboliquement de toutes ces
fautes
une manière de ce pass poser les bonnes
questions de ne pas rechercher où sont
les responsables les vrais responsables
car il existe bien les vrais
responsables ne faudrait-il pas avant
tout vous pencher sur les surfaces
disponibles dans les grandes entreprises
les banques les compagnies d'assurances
les administrations l'état dans ceux qui
sont sur le terrain ça veut bien aussi
que ce dernier l'état ne finance plus
les institutions dédiées à un niveau
suffisant et vous êtes bien placé à
paris même pour faire libérer des
logements sociaux ou de fonction
qu'occupe des personnes qui ne devraient
pas les avoir alors concrètement madame
la ministre
qu'avez vous fait pour anticiper tout
cela il est temps aujourd'hui de le dire
à la représentation nationale
si monsieur françois d'amis ministre
chargé de la ville merci monsieur le
président d'abord monsieur le sénateur
je vous prie d'excuser à cécile duflot
qui est retenu à un colloque important
puisqu'il s'agit d'un colloque qui
commémore le 30e anniversaire de la loi
quillot il noie importante pour le
logement social dans notre notre pays
la ministre de l'égalité des territoires
et et du logement l'a rappelé mardi à
l'assemblée nationale monsieur le
sénateur il n'y a qu'une seule question
qui vaille
comment s'attaque ton et quelles
réponses apporter ton à la crise en
crise du logement c'est la seule
question qui vaille il ya aujourd'hui
1500 demandes par jour pour lesquelles
on ne trouve pas de solutions en matière
de logement d'urgence les services du
115 sont saturés dont plusieurs régions
comme l'ile-de-france et le rhône
il ya 47 familles 47 mille familles
pardon ils sont reconnues prioritaires
au titre de la loi sur le droit au
logement et qui sont en attente d'un
logement pour tout simplement pouvoir
vivre dignement
mais vous malheureusement vous préférez
plutôt que de nous aider à trouver des
réponses à ces questions majeures vous
préférez provoqué alimenté en vêtements
et une polémique
une polémique qui est plutôt un stérile
et indignant monsieur le sénateur
maintenant sortez la santé de ces
polémiques et soyons clairs
il nous faut un socle de solidarité pour
être à la hauteur de ces enjeux
il en va de notre responsabilité
collective le premier ministre a rappelé
le 1er novembre dernier
nous devons trouver une réponse à celles
et ceux qui se trouvent aujourd'hui dans
la rue alors que dans le même temps des
bâtiments vides existe dans le
patrimoine de nombreuses personnes
morales c'est le sens de l'appel qui a
été adressé à tous les propriétaires à
toutes les personnes morales et à
commencer par l'état pour mettre à
disposition son patrimoine leed pour
l'utiliser comme un lieu d'hébergement
et pas plus tard qu'hier cécile duflot
s'est rendu avec guillaume pépy dans un
ancien foyer de cheminots à ivry que la
sncf a mis à disposition de l'état cet
hiver pour accueillir des personnes sans
domicile fixe c'est à cela un signe
encourageant
vous le voyez à l'appel de madame d'un
ministre a produit ses premiers
résultats
s'ils ne sont pas suffisants alors nous
en viendrons bien entendu aux
réquisitions sur la base de l'inventaire
qui a été réalisé par le préfet de la
région ile de france qui a recensé une
soixantaine de bâtiments appartenant
depuis plus de deux ans et qui sont
vacants à des personnes morales
sachez monsieur le sénateur que la
réquisition est une solution d'urgence
mais nous nous limitons pas et nous ne
limiterons pas notre action à ces
mesures
loin s'en faut l'objectif du
gouvernement c'est de tenir l'engagement
du président de la république celui de
construire 1500 le cent cinquante mille
logements sociaux par an c'est
l'ambition du gouvernement qui sera
faire preuve du volontarisme nécessaire
pour parvenir à apporter une réponse
concrète à la crise du logement
madame car il ne plairont pour le groupe
socialiste apparentés
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
aurélie filippetti ministre de la
culture et de la communication le
président film l'imprévision président
de france télévisions a adressé à la
direction générale de outre mer 1ère
france ô des directives mentionnant un
programme d'économies drastiques a
effectué par l'outre-mer france ô
deviendrait la chaîne dédiée des enfants
pendant la journée et serait la chaîne
vitrine d outre mer la nuit
les huit stations régionales d'outre-mer
verraient leur outil de production
disparaître totalement les jt air
journaux télévisés régionaux seraient
diffusés
décrochage sur les programmes de france
3 la direction envisage de fermer
complètement dans un premier temps deux
stations wallis et futuna et
saint-pierre-et-miquelon du fait de la
mise en place du décrochage et de la fin
de l'été les pays le siège de malakoff
perdrait la direction des programmes des
autres maires première il perdrait aussi
puisque sa fermeture est envisagée
lagence d'imagés de sujets de france
télévisions la itv qui est une filiale
du réseau outre mer 1ère ce qui est
totalement contradictoire avec le
travail initié par l'inrs
ce plan d'économies signifie tout
simplement la fin de l'audiovisuel
public d'outre-mer qui sera réduit à sa
plus simple expression plus aucune
collectivité n'aurait démission
d'actualité ni d'autres productions
locales
cette hypothèse pardon vous en
conviendrez n'est pas envisageable
cela signifierait aussi nombre d'emplois
supprimés dans nos collectivités
alors que les agents participent
largement à l'économie des dom comme
l'état je l'espère ne saurait se laisser
imposer ce genre de décision aussi
discriminatoire qu'injustifiée par le
président de france télévisions au
niveau de la gestion des collectivités
d'outre-mer la fermeture des stations
serait un acte ignorant la réalité
sociale et économique de l'outre-mer
français
cette décision inadmissible éteindre et
la voix d outre-mer et n'irait
l'existence mais aussi l'intérêt de par
leur richesse des cultures ultramarines
ce serait de plus éteindre la voix de la
france sur toute la surface du globe
madame la ministre sachant qu'il ne
saurait y avoir de différence de
traitement entre les huit stations le
gouvernement laissera t-il s'éteindre la
voix d outre-mer à l'heure même où les
collectivités ultramarines sans mise en
avant parce qu'elle participe à la
richesse et au rayonnement de la france
dans le monde
merci madame aurélie filippetti ministre
de la culture de la communication
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice karine claireaux vous le savez
le groupe france télévisions doit
prendre toute sa part à l'effort de
redressement des finances publiques que
le gouvernement a initié et donc nous
travaillons avec le
président du groupe france télévisions à
un avenant au contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens qui va donc permettre de
redéfinir un certain nombre de périmètre
de chercher des économies et de rendre
plus efficace l'action des programmes
sur les chaînes du service public
néanmoins cet avenant au com et négocier
et travailler avec la tutelle de la
direction de france télévisions et donc
les les propos les craintes que vous
avez exprimées ici je peux vous le dire
concernant les outre mer 1ère ne sont
pas fondées en effet nous sommes
extrêmement satisfaits du développement
des chaînes d outre-mer 1ère les neuf
outre-mer 1ère qui existe maintenant
depuis deux ans qui ont eu à faire face
à un contexte difficile puisque avec la
diffusion numérique terrestre
eh bien les chaînes d du service public
national de france télévisions qui
auparavant étaient diffusés sur les
outre-mer 1ère maintenant sont
accessibles directement
donc il a fallu reconfigurer repenser
les programmes d outre mer 1ère cela
s'est fait depuis deux ans et cela s'est
plutôt bien fait le public et est au
rendez-vous les missions de service
public aussi sont au rendez vous et donc
il n'est pas question pour le
gouvernement de remettre en cause le
fonctionnement des outre-mer 1ère
d'autre part je profite de cette
question pour vous dire que c'est la
représentation même des outre-mer sur
les chaînes du service public et y
compris dans l'hexagone qui doit être
renforcée et donc j'ai demandé
au président de france télévisions de
réfléchir à une meilleure représentation
et une meilleure présence d outre-mer
sur les chaînes qui sont diffusées dans
l'hexagone à l'occasion de l'année des
outre-mer d'ailleurs un effort avait été
fait et je crois que tout le monde en
avait été extrêmement satisfait tout le
monde avait vu à quel point cette
richesse de nos outre-mer était attendue
par l'ensemble de nos concitoyens est
partout sur notre territoire à quel
point la représentation des d outre mer
et non seulement évidemment tout à fait
naturelle mais aussi une source
d'enrichissement une source de diversité
dans l'ensemble des programmes des
chaînes du groupe france télévisions
donc madame la sénatrice je veux vous
vous rassurer malgré les efforts
budgétaires nécessaires la fonction de
la vocation d d outre mer 1ère ne sera
pas remise en cause et l'outre-mer reste
bien une priorité pour le gouvernement y
compris sur les services publics
merci madame sophie primas pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues et ma question s'adresse à
monsieur françois lamy ministre délégué
chargé de la ville monsieur le ministre
le 2 septembre dernier il a été confiée
à monsieur pascal auzannet une mission
visant à fixer les priorités concernant
les équipements de transports du grand
paris
la présentation du rapport a été différé
le gouvernement fait preuve d'un
étonnant mutisme à ce sujet même si
parfois vous me permettrez cette
réflexion l'attend suscite le désir
il génère en l'occurrence une véritable
angoisse angoisse partagée par de
nombreux élus locaux quelle que soit
leur tendance politique
ce sentiment est naturellement alimentée
par le choix de votre gouvernement de
renoncer à inscrire dans la loi de
programmation budgétaire le milliard
d'euros nécessaires à la poursuite de ce
projet par la suppression du
commissariat général pour le
développement de la vallée de la seine
présidé par monsieur antoine ruffenach
par le gel des grands travaux engagés je
citerai le canal seine nord où le port
d'achères et par de nombreux
questionnements sur l'avenir des lignes
de métro et rer du grand paris des
transports aussi mon interrogation
portera-t-elle particulièrement sur
l'une de ses infrastructures
le rer 1,10 et hall et son prolongement
à l'ouest jusqu'à mantes la jolie que
certaines hypothèses
remettrait en cause une telle décision
monsieur le ministre serait dramatique
je pèse mes mots pour le développement
du territoire seine aval décrété
opération d'intérêt national
tous les élus de ce territoire se sont
engagés avec volontarisme dans la
construction de logements 2500 parents
ils ne pourront pas défendre ses projets
d'urbanisation
si l'état ne tient pas ses engagements
et c'est le projet de rer est abandonné
or ce territoire industriel est
particulièrement touchée par les
difficultés des constructeurs
automobiles renault et peugeot et de
l'ensemble des sous-traitants
il connaît une vive accélération des
pertes d'emplois et une dégradation très
forte et continue des conditions de
transport véritable frein à
l'implantation de nouvelles entreprises
pourtant paradoxalement ces entreprises
contribuent largement financement du
grand paris par la taxe spéciale
d'équipement et la taxe sur les bureaux
qui grèvent leur compétitivité et en
contrepartie ne leur apporte pas
d'attractivité dans un tel contexte
monsieur le ministre
ma question est simple pouvez vous nous
confirmer votre engagement en faveur du
prolongement du rer e eole qui vous
l'aurez compris conditionne la
construction de plusieurs milliers de
logements par an et en particulier
pouvez-vous nous assurer que la phase
une du projet sera prioritairement la
ligne mantes la jolie la défense
promesses historique d'êta cette
décision rejoindrait vos propres
objectifs en matière de logement et
permettrait d'améliorer l'attractivité
industriel et économique ne serait
territoire du nord des yvelines qui en a
un besoin vital
merci merci monsieur françois lamy
ministre chargé de la ville merci
monsieur le président madame madame la
sénatrice comme vous l'avez rappelé le
gouvernement a nommé pascal auzannet
pour faire une mission sur le grand
paris serait dé des options de
séquencement de l'ensemble de ce projet
qu'ils ouvrent appel est un projet qui
tient à coeur de ce gouvernement mais
qui souhaite que soit menée à bien
johann hay vous va rendre ses
conclusions dans quelques jours donc
vous n'avez plus que quelques jours pour
que ce l'espère vos désirs soit exaucé
en ce qui concerne le projet eole qui
consiste effectivement à prolonger le
rer e à l'ouest entre paris et sa
banlieue ouest
c'est un projet structurant 1 est
important ils participent les enjeux du
transport quotidien pour les franciliens
et les parisiens outre son intérêt en
termes de report modal
il permettra une meilleure desserte des
territoires participera leur
développement économique
il est par ailleurs un des éléments clés
de la désaturation de la ligne a du rer
qui assure aujourd'hui la plupart des
trajets quotidiens entre l'est et
l'ouest de la région parisienne
ce projet ambitieux a été amenée à
évoluer dans le temps et surtout dans
son évaluation puisque lors du débat
public en 2010 le coût du projet avait
été estimé entre 2,2 et 2 8 milliards
d'euros et en 2012 l'enquète publique a
été menée sur la base d'études plus
précise un nouveau suffrages a été
établi à hauteur de 3 7 milliards
d'euros
vous connaissez les priorités du
gouvernement en termes de déplacements
amélioration des conditions de transport
quotidien réduction de la fracture
territoriale et rénovation des réseaux
existants
soyez donc assurée à madame la sénatrice
que le gouvernement soutient fortement
ce projet il fait partie du plan de
mobilisation du la région ile-de-france
que ces premiers financements sont
d'ailleurs prévues dans la convention
spécifique signée avec le conseil
régional en lien avec le stif et la
région le gouvernement fera donc ses
meilleurs efforts pour que ce projet
malgré son coût soit menée à bien car il
est un des éléments clé de
l'amélioration des transports du
quotidien en région ile de france
on est à monsieur jean françois husson
pour la réunion administrative
dessinateur de figurant sur la liste
aucun groupe
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement
monsieur le ministre certaines communes
rurales du grand test rencontrent des
difficultés dans la mise en oeuvre de
leurs projets d'installations
photovoltaïques dans un contexte de
transition énergétique les pouvoirs
publics au premier rang desquels l'état
n'ont cessé d'oeuvrer pour la promotion
de ces technologies en y voyant une
réponse pertinente aux problèmes de la
production d'électricité
s'inscrivant dans une démarche de
développement durable les collectivités
territoriales
faut-il le rappeler ont un rôle majeur à
jouer dans la maîtrise de l'énergie
ainsi que dans la promotion des énergies
renouvelables
en effet cette filière permet à la fois
de développer une politique territoriale
de production d'énergie propre en
apportant une valorisation
environnementale et en mobilisant les
acteurs locaux entraînant ainsi de
nouvelles dynamiques de développement
pour les territoires ruraux
ces projets constituent de véritables
investissements d'avenir
et pour illustrer concrètement je
prendrai le cas de badonviller en
meurthe-et-moselle où la communauté de
communes s'est fortement mobilisée en
effet l'économie de ce bassin a été
profondément marqué par une activité
industrielle very faïencerie textile est
les pouvoirs publics ont été unanimes
pour encourager accompagner la
reconversion de ce territoire et plus
particulièrement pour ses friches
industrielles
cette commune a donc entrepris la
requalification du site désaffecté des
faïenceries pour l'orienter vers une
utilisation à vocation d' activités
économiques par un portage de
l'établissement public foncier de
lorraine un site de 14 hectares ainsi pu
être réhabilité il a fait l'objet d'une
rétrocession est la communauté de
communes a choisi d'implanter une
centrale photovoltaïque sur une partie
de ce terrain la commission de
régulation de l'énergie réunis au mois
de juin devait après analyse statuer sur
ce projet proposons une utilisation
moderne exemplaires et durable de
friches industrielles
malheureusement les résultats de
l'instruction du dossier menée par la
creuse ont exclusivement privilégier les
projets situés au sud de la france
écartant par là même tous les projets
situés dans la partie nord de notre
hexagone
si le taux d'ensoleillement est un
critère à prendre en considération
il ne me semble pas équitable qu'il soit
un critère exclusif la validation de ces
projets ne doit pas reposer sur la seule
valeur de rachat ou sur le seul coût
fixe en euros du kilowattheure produit
il doit être regard d'un niveau plus
global intégrant notamment la création
d'emplois et la confortation de
l'attractivité territoriale
une attention particulière
et un soutien renforcé doivent être
apportés par l'état
lorsque ces projets se situent en zone
de revitalisation rurale ce qui est le
cas pour badonviller c'est pourquoi
monsieur le ministre je vous demande de
bien vouloir m'indiquer quelles mesures
seront mises en oeuvre pour permettre
aux territoires ruraux de s'inscrire
véritablement à la fois dans une année
dynamique de transition énergétique que
vous appelez de vos voeux comme nous et
dans le cadre d'une reconversion
industrielle
je souhaite également connaître la place
que vous entendez donner à ces mêmes
territoires qui souffrent objectivement
d'une rupture d'égalité alors même que
le ministère dont madame du feu à la
charge porte explicitement le principe
d'égalité des territoires dans son
intitulé le défi consiste aujourd'hui à
passer de la parole aux actes
merci monsieur alain vidalis ministre
chargé des relations avec deux plans le
maire merci monsieur le président ce
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur jean
françois husson je vous prie de bien
vouloir excuser la ministre de
l'écologie du développement durable et
de l'énergie delphine batho qui
représente actuellement la france à la
18e conférence sur le changement
climatique à doha le précédent
gouvernement je le rappelle est revenu
en catastrophe sur les tarifs d'achat de
l'électricité solaire le résultat c'est
la destruction de 10000 emplois dans
notre pays dans le secteur
photovoltaïque
en deux ans la politique du gouvernement
c'est le développement massif des
énergies renouvelables dans le cadre de
la transition énergétique
c'est la création d'emplois dans nos
territoires les mesures d'urgence pour
la filière ont été annoncées par le
président de la république lors de la
conférence environnementale dans la
tente du cadre tarifaire stable attendu
par les professionnels qui sortira du
débat national sur la transition
énergétique que vient de lancer delphine
batho la semaine dernière le
gouvernement a ainsi pris un certain
nombre de mesures pour redonner un
souffle à la filière photovoltaïque tout
en maîtrisant leurs coûts tout en
privilégiant la qualité et l'innovation
et en s'assurant que son développement
bénéficient le plus possible
au tissu industriel et économique
français et européens le prochain appel
d'offres pour les grandes installations
qui sera très prochainement lancer
répondra à ces objectifs
il privilégiera aussi les installations
des installations sur grandes toitures
pour éviter la consommation des espaces
agricoles pour les petites installations
plusieurs mesures d'urgence sont
proposées dont notamment une
bonification pour les équipements
produits en europe
ces mesures d'urgence visent à sécuriser
l'activité des entreprises qui créent de
la valeur ajoutée dans nos territoires
en cohérence avec le patriotisme
écologique que nous souhaitons
promouvoir comme vous le savez monsieur
le sénateur l'appel d'offres pour les
grandes installations dont delphine
batho a annoncé les résultats en juillet
dernier
ne prévoyez pas de critères
géographiques susceptible d'encourager
le développement de projets
photovoltaïques dans les zones moins
ensoleillées comme la lorraine
néanmoins cet appel d'offres a
globalement tenu ses promesses en terme
de soutien à l'innovation et de création
de filière industrielle française
compétitive
parmi les cinq fabricants de modules
photovoltaïques ayant remporté les
volumes les plus importants 4 produisent
en france mais le gouvernement vous
entend et vous rejoins sur la nécessité
de favoriser la création de valeur
ajoutée locale et l'utilisation de
terrains en reconversion pour les
centrales solaires au sol
madame la ministre delphine batho
s'engage à examiner leur prise en compte
pour la définition des conditions pour
le prochain appel d'offres merci mes
chers collègues nous en avons fini avec
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement que vous avez pu suivre en
direct sur notre antenne on se retrouve
tout de suite pour refaire la séance
avec nos invités